the next time someone you work with says
I'll get itchy by end of week just slap
them or just say that doesn't work for
me because it might come at least we say
end of week instead end of day is
better if you make the default in your
business that end of day becomes the new
end of week you move seven times faster
as a company which is crazy because if
you need to do a project and someone
turns it around a week and then they
turn the next thing around a week the
next person turns around a week what
took 21 days can take three days in your
business the opportunity cost of how
much more every single project starting
earlier would have made you that
compounds is what creates breathtaking
growth